avec moi sur ce plateau Stéphane malong
bonjour bonjour
est-ce que le suspense autour du
renouvellement de cette accord qui
expire officiellement ce soir inquiète
autant sur le continent africain
vous faites bien de parler de suspense
Pauline parce que on est dans un
processus de négociation et que l'accord
court jusqu'à à 0 heure donc qui peut
toujours y avoir un rebondissement un
revirement pour revenir à l'Afrique
pourquoi en s'inquiète en s'inquiète
parce que une un non renouvellement de
cet accord pour reconduire à une
situation qu'on a connu un peu partout
dans le monde mais surtout en Afrique au
début de la de cette guerre en Ukraine
souvenez-vous les prix des denrées
alimentaires avaient augmenté fortement
ils avaient augmenté pourquoi parce
qu'il y avait une inquiétude sur la
disponibilité à la fois du blé
ukrainien mais aussi de du blé russe il
y avait un embargo autour des donc cette
situation avec créer une inflation
générale des produits alimentaires mais
aussi des intrants dans l'agriculture et
si aujourd'hui il y a pas cet accord là
on va revenir à une situation où tout
est bloqué de partout et donc inflation
un qui dit inflation parlent de de
d'impact sur les pays africains alors
pour bien pour bien comprendre ce qui se
joue il faut savoir que aujourd'hui s'il
y a pas d'accord c'est-à-dire il y a pas
de blé ukrainien qui sort de de cette de
cette région là de la mer Noire cela
signifie sans doute que les restrictions
sur les propres exportations de la
Russie vont se faire forte et donc il y
aura pas de blé en tout cas il y aura
moins qu'en moindre quantité sur les
marchés internationaux et donc en
Afrique de blé russe de blé russe à la
fois écrivain parce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que
certes des pays comme la Tunisie
l'Egypte dépendent très fortement de du
blé ukrainien pour leur consommation
sont on est autour de plus de la moitié
de ce qu'ils ont inscrits consomment
mais sur le continent un peu partout
c'est surtout le blé russe qui est
acheté et donc il y a cette inquiétude
là pas de pas d'accord signifie pas de
blé ukrainien mais pas de blé russe non
plus et donc augmentation de de plis du
prix des des produits de première
nécessité et au-delà même des céréales
et des et des produits agricoles on
pense aussi aux fertilisant que la
Russie fournit essentiellement des pays
subsahariens je pense à des pays comme
le Sénégal ou le Bénin ou même des pays
comme le Mali ou le Burkina parce qu'ils
sont des producteurs de coton et qui
dépendent très fortement des
fertilisants de fertilisants qui
arrivent qui viennent essentiellement de
de la de la Russie donc ce contexte
global où il y a un risque d'inflation
sur
souvenez-vous les Africains n'ont pas
pris clairement position dans cette dans
cette guerre ils n'ont pas condamné ils
n'ont pas pour la plupart soutenu non
plus clairement
Vladimir Poutine faire cette démarche de
médiation est une façon de dire à la
fois russe et aux Ukrainiens
aller vers une solution pacifique
négociée pour qu'on pour qu'il y ait pas
une conséquence à l'échelle mondiale
notamment chez nous les risques de
sécurité alimentaire mais c'est aussi
une façon pour les Africains de dire en
fait nous ne sommes pas indifférents à
ce qui se passe dans cette région parce
qu'une guerre une guerre c'est
dramatique c'est atroce et des vies
humaines qui se jouent et c'est toute la
géopolitique mondiale aussi qui se joue
donc on est préoccupé par notre propre
sort lié à la sécurité alimentaire mais
on est aussi concerné touché par ce qui
se passe là donc il y a une dimension
politique diplomatique qui qui qui
justifie aussi cette démarche là pour
aller plus loin Stéphane est-ce qu'on
pourrait est-ce qu'on peut se demander
si il va dire Poutine à intérêt à créer
une situation qui pourrait pénaliser à
ce point
des pays africains dont certains sont
ces très proches alliés alliés qu'il va
ou en tout cas collaborateur amis qu'il
va dont il va inviter certains à Moscou
dans quelques semaines
il est difficile de répondre à cette
question on a jusqu'à minuit ce soir
pour voir ce qui va se passer mais une
chose est certaine Vladimir Poutine
d'après ce qu'il dit cet accord ne
bénéfique pas selon lui est censé
essentiellement africains lui dit que
sur les 33 millions de tonnes qui ont
été exportés pendant cette année pendant
l'année écoulée seulement 3 % en
profiter au pays pauvres notamment
africains parce qu'au contexte
évidemment évidemment l'Union africaine
mais il faut aussi se rappeler que pour
les Africains on pense à cette visite de
Macky salade du président sénégalais à
Sotchi il y a il y a un an un an et demi
pour passer un message c'est-à-dire
faites en sorte que nous ne soyons pas
impactés par la hausse des prix et donc
la non-disponibilité de produits
agricole sur les marchés donc il y a ce
jeu d'équilibré d'ailleurs on lit on
comprend bien le message de Vladimir
Poutine quand il parle aux
occidentaux il dit l'accord n'a pas test
d'objectif et donc je ne vais pas le
renouveler et quand il s'adresse aux
Africains il dit je vais faire en sorte
de vous alimenter en blé notamment mais
au-delà du blé je vais faire en sorte
que notre coopération se développe sur
le plan commercial sur le plan
économique sur le plan énergétique bref
faire en sorte que vous ne soyez pas
impactés par par cette situation merci
beaucoup
pour votre analyse